que pensez-vous madame des gens qui font
chou blanc
digérer voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle
l'odeur de santé monsieur bah c'est
reconnaître une femme qui est enceinte
pour son odeur vous êtes culotté oui oui
mais pourquoi vous riez c'est une
question qui surprend quand même dans la
rue surtout de ce temps-là que
pensez-vous des gens qui passent la main
madame j'aime pas vous aimez pas quoi
j'aime pas ça même dans le dos ou sur le
bras j'aime pas compris pote voyez-vous
ce qu'on appelle les feux de la rampe
monsieur oui qu'est-ce que c'est cadora
mal aux fesses à force de glisser sur la
Rome traverser du désert oui c'est
pareil
je crois qu'il a essayé de faire la même
chose quoi essayer de participer au
niveau des pilotes